basic appreciation of Statistics are
used pretty much every day to a point
where it's a kind of superpower and so
just having done what you might call you
know statistics to a level standard and
having a basic grasp of yes but actually
is unbelievably valuable in business or
in virtually any other context there's a
trade-off between exploration and
exploitation obviously you're a total
idiot if you don't exploit what you
already know okay if you make no use of
pre-existing knowledge but you're
equally foolish albeit in the slightly
longer term if you don't keep exploring
but simply exploit what you know on the
assumption that it will never change and
your knowledge is utterly complete and
incapable of uh Improvement